the first place I went to with UNICEF
was Nigeria then Angola then Darfur and
r 4 and r 4 then I've traveled now 11 x
to the Darfur region and eastern chad
not always with UNICEF more often on my
own twice to Central African Republic
once to Haiti with UNICEF but there are
situations in some of the countries i've
mentioned where we as UNICEF we can't
say certain things just because we need
access to the children so I step aside
and just as as as an individual mia
farrow I could say whatever I want and I
do and it's really since mine my first
trip to Darfur in 2004 and then again in
2006 that I witnessed things that I
could just no longer be silent about and
it changed my life I don't even I don't
want to do movies anymore I don't want
to act anymore the things I used to be
I'm not they gave me the opportunity to
work with UNICEF and now I just want to
do this full-time
at least in democracies we can influence
our governments there was a late Senator
Paul Simon an American senator now dad
who said that if just 100 people had
written in or contacted their their
leadership during the Rwandan genocide
that our government would have
intervened whatever you feel about that
it does place squarely on our shoulders
gives us a real sense of our
responsibility as as individuals now I I
come from a generation that brought an
end to a war because we considered it to
be unjust and this was the Vietnam War
and it was individuals one by one taking
to the streets writing to the government
protesting on campuses margit peaceful
protests for the most part we expressed
our our view to our government and I
believe that you know if what the late
Senator Paul Simon said just a hundred
people from every district and by that
means every congressional district er
every senator wrote in every state out
of all the millions just a hundred right
in we represent millions so it gives us
you know a sense of power and I think
responsibility to be the one that's
heard many countries they don't care
what you say it's much harder to have
laws passed but we can work in subtle
ways within our communities certainly I
as a mother of seven sons I'm fourteen
children but seven sons my obligation to
bring my children up in a way that we
will resolve our conflicts peacefully we
can all do that
as as parents as citizens and within our
communities to help young people resolve
their conflicts peacefully and pursue an
avenue other than violence when we try
to resolve just locally within our
communities whatever conflict might
arise